Time magazine's Person of the Year is
our president-elect and person who
definitely at some point his life is
yelled she's him Donald Trump now he's
an eighties movie villain you guys he's
an 80s movie villain he's the one who
whenever that story is he keeps the
nerds from accomplishing whatever thing
it is and then they got in the end like
teach him a lesson he's like nerds like
that's him
now do not a Trump fan I would like to
remind you the title goes to someone who
was influential not someone who was
necessarily like the greatest person
ever if that was the case every year
would just go to the rock I mean he's
the greatest person ever why don't they
just do that to help don't keep things
in perspective here's what a wise man
once said on Twitter quote the Time
magazine list of the 100 most
influential people is a joke and a stunt
of a magazine that will like Newsweek
soon be dead bad list who said that
again alright Time Magazine's 2016
minute of the Year Donald Trump so
comedians one of their list is idle
Trump considered to be bad Joe Randazzo
list of the 2.8 million more people who
actually voted for Hillary Clinton in
the election than him alright thanks for
that maybe we aren't the waiting list
for a new slovenian why
who wants to be the second First Lady
Jon Gabrus Schindler's List not the
movie but the actual